foreign
[Music]
Banks look at you cracking the whip
um I don't know if you missed the last
black people meeting but that phrase is
problematic right along with master
bedroom and Plantation Shadows
yeah I got the memo
doing here oh will wanted me to hop on
the ox for the party but you know I can
stick around keep you covered
yeah I like that
all right okay so thirsty Chef huh don't
even get me started look you look fine
as hell but I don't know it just it
doesn't seem like you it's not look I'll
tell you everything I just need a strong
drink first
let's get involving it
over here come on
thank you
can you believe that I know right just
making themselves at home
the nerve
audacity
I mean
this room isn't even sexy
no right like
you know what's cool and everything but
it's just an office you know
don't check it
it could be my parents thinking we
burned down the house or something
kylo he's at this influencer event in
Hollywood and I'm gonna go down there
and tell him he needs to take that
thirsty Chef [ __ ] down now
you ready I'll stay ready
hey
I'm sorry that it took so long
I smelled it
look they offered me 15K a post
can't put a price on dignity
okay father
jazz
it's just business okay I can't pass up
this opportunity I mean my engagement is
off the chain and then once I Bank all
these followers I can reach out to them
with my content the way I want to
no I get all that I just didn't think
that uh
she would sell your soul
okay I wouldn't expect you to get it I
mean you've had Instagram for like two
minutes
I understood it enough for you to drag
my ass down here for me to get your back
okay I'm sorry
I mean I can give you gas money
yeah okay
check please yeah no problem
okay
what's up so
I'm very sorry that I went off on you
I wasn't cool I apologize well I
appreciate that but I would much rather
hear like
Jazz you were right
what about jazz you're a pain in the ass
but no you were right
I haven't told my parents yet but I told
Kyla to [ __ ] off and I quit the house
I bet it felt good to stand up to [ __ ]
boy 5 000. it really did it really did
but now I'm in a situation where I'm
staying at a hotel until I find my new
place and I owe kylo fifty thousand
dollars for breaking the contract 50 G's
you got that type of bread I'm gonna
figure something out I know you will you
always do hey you fine
like Chloe Bailey have mercy
hey girl hey boy
okay good nobody's here
kind of wish Kyla was here so I could
slap his tall ass look I brought you
here to help me get my stuff and keep
Lookout I don't need you fighting
anybody but I appreciate the sentence
hey whatever it takes no I've been
looking for an opportunity to impress
you
well I'll be impressed if you could get
up there and get my sign for me not a
problem
hey I got a question though yes
just don't understand why we're in here
stealing your own stuff like can't you
just borrow 50 G's from your dad and
others be over with let's not go there
okay I need to do this on my own
oh you gotta do things on your own
okay
well
a Little Help from
you but no I do owe you one oh well in
that case
I was thinking that maybe after here we
can go back to my crib now I'm not the
type of cook that you are but I can show
you my cooking skills cook you a little
dinner that could be cute
or
I'm staying at this Bungalow at this
five-star hotel maybe we could go there
and Order room service
hey real talk
I'm really glad you left the influence
house yeah
but don't get used to this hotel okay
when my parents see this credit card
bill I'm gonna have some explaining to
do
but this is nice I'm trying to keep
whatever this is
going for as long as possible
yes
I am a genius I'm a genius okay so Ivy's
post and my mom's Gala got her followed
by Edward inning full and Aurora James
oh that's that's great
uh am I supposed to know the [ __ ] those
people are basically the level of clout
they are on Ivy hasn't even tapped into
that yet this is big hey and you got her
there
just like you got my record store up to
5 000 followers
ah I love how proud you are of such a
small number okay you can keep the jokes
but I mean the truth is you know how to
strategize him and I just feel like
that's worth way more than just
posing for some pics you know I look
good in those pictures though period
Well I know you look good in those
pictures
but I'm just saying I want you to
stop thinking of Ivy as some lifeline
and start thinking about us
a partner
oh my God it's will
sorry good
[Music]
thank you
[Music]